great job thank you welcome to Hannity
it is another major breaking news night
tonight in a moment a live report from
the border our own bill malugin where
apprehensions now are peaking at over
ten thousand uh per day including
individuals on the terror watch list
thousand more uh have evaded arrest and
as we speak we have homeless veterans in
this country they are now being kicked
out of hotel rooms just to accommodate
those that are breaking our laws and our
sovereignty and not respecting our
borders but Joe Biden he seems to think
it's all big one laughing matter Texas
congressmanship Roy he will join us with
reaction straight ahead and later more
from Judge jeanine's interview with the
attorney representing that Marine vet
who was charged with manslaughter in the
death of a violent homeless man on a New
York City subway but first tonight house
Judiciary chairman Jim Jordan Greg
Jarrett John Solomon Sarah Carter all
the bands back together the great one
Mark Levin also will weigh in on
tonight's top story a story that was
once near and dear to the hearts of
every Trump hater in this country take a
look new Fallout tonight in the Russia
investigation Russia Russia's Russian
Russians Russians Russians Russia Russia
Russia Russia Russian Russia Russia
Russia Russian Russia Russia Russians
Russian Russia Russia Russia is Russia
Russia the Russian Russia Russia Russia
Russians the Russian Russia and the
Russia the Russian Russia Russian Russia
Russia Russia Russia Russian
now the left Russia hysteria has
officially come to an end after years
and years and years of waiting with the
2020 election safely now in the rear
view mirror the doj has finally
published the findings of the Durham
probe remember that a long story short
every single thing that we reported to
you on this program we were correct
we've been Vindicated time and again
especially today everything the media
mob reported for almost three long years
day in and day out nothing but lies and
conspiracy theories Adam Schiff was the
congenital liar that we told you about
it only took the doj seven years to get
to the truth it's pretty incredible
damaging corruption that sadly is now
going unpunished and will remain
unpunished but tonight to be clear there
is no dispute Trump Russia collusion
never ever happened it was a hoax and a
lie but more appropriately it looks more
like an attempted coup a nearly
three-year running political local smear
job against Donald J Trump all
orchestride Orchestra orchestrated by
democrats with the help of the doj and
the FBI and of course the never-ending
lies of the media mob they spoke with
one voice and according to Durham's
findings there was no legitimate reason
for the FBI to even open their
investigation into trump-russia
collusion laughably named Crossfire
hurricane quote the crossfire hurricane
investigators did not and could not
corroborate any of the substantive
allegations contained in the steel
reporting nor was the nor was still able
to produce corroboration for any of the
reported allegations even after being
offered one million dollars or more by
the FBI for such corroboration now of
course Christopher Steele and his dirty
dossier that was all funded by Hillary
Clinton and her campaign and the DNC
that they controlled it was the very
basis of Crossfire hurricane as door and
put a quote there was significant
Reliance on investigative leads provided
or funded directly or indirectly by
Trump's political opponents in other
words in the height of a presidential
election the Clinton campaign literally
spoon-fed a baseless political smear
against her opponent to the FBI the FBI
then eagerly tried to corroborate all
these basic smears and when they
couldn't well the bureau still used the
unverifiable Steele dossier to then go
to a fisa court Lido a fisa court saying
it was verified it's unverifiable for
the purpose of ruining one man's life
Carter page to spy it on a back doorway
on the Trump campaign later his
transition team and then a president of
the United States now the totally un uh
the total dossier was the very basis of
a fisa application three subsequent
renewals they lied four times to a fisa
court lying to a court at the top of a
of a fisa war and it says verified it
was all unverifiable even after swearing
that evidence was true and verified
Durham found that the FBI under comey's
tremendous leadership even withheld
exculpatory evidence from the fisa court
quote FBI Personnel working on that same
fisa application displayed at best a
Cavalier attitude towards accuracy and
completeness the report continues quote
FBI Personnel also repeatedly
disregarded important requirements when
they continue to seek renewals of that
visor of surveillance while
acknowledging both then and in hindsight
that they did not genuinely believe
there was probable cause to believe that
the target was knowingly engaged in
clandestine intelligence act activities
on behalf of a foreign power or
knowingly helping another person in such
activities let's put it simply the FBI
knew it was BS so did the Clinton
campaign so did Adam schiffs so did Jim
Comey so did Peter strucking company so
did clappers so did Brandon and so did
the entire media mob everyone went Hook
Line and Sinker everyone pushing the
Russia collusion coup was lying to flip
a presidential election well for example
here's Hillary Clinton on October 31st
2016 quote computer scientists have
apparently uncovered a covert serving
linking the Trump organization to a
Russia bank that was a lie a lie that
Hillary just can't seem to quit take a
look
I believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president I think it's also
critical to understand that as I've been
telling candidates who have come to see
me you can run the best campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you
wow what has happened to our country
Hillary Clinton is delusional and she's
not the only one congenital liar Adam
Schiff said there was ample evidence of
collusion that was a lie remember Fang
Fang's best friend former lover also
championing the evidence of collusion
Eric swalwell he was lying and we could
go on and on and on here are some of the
biggest political and deep State Liars
in their own words you decide do you
believe the president right now has been
an agent of the Russians yes I I think
there's more evidence than it is yes and
I I think all the arrows point that
direction and I haven't seen a single
piece of evidence that he's not I think
he's afraid of the president of Russia
why um well I think one can speculate as
to why that the Russians may have
something on him personally that they
could always roll out and make his life
more difficult this past weekend is
illustrative of uh what a great case
officer uh Vladimir Putin is he knows
how to handle an asset and that's what
he's doing with the president the
American people need to know whether the
Russians still have something they can
hold over the president's head the
president of the United States so our
work is far from done I can certainly
say with confidence that there is
significant evidence of collusion
between the campaign and Russia now it
wasn't just the Deep state for years if
you turned on fake news CNN msdnc it was
all lies 24 7. take a look based on our
own reporting and word from numerous
official sources the dossier in fact is
far from bogus no major thing from the
dossier has been conclusively disproven
we already know that the part about the
coverage that they have on him with sex
actions is supposed to be true the
intelligence Community has corroborated
whoever paid for it has corroborated a
lot of the information that was in there
to begin with correct there are actually
substantial portions of what was in the
steel dossier which was a raw
intelligence document that have indeed
checked out you know I think we're going
to actually have to stop calling it the
infamous dossier increasingly it's the
accurate dossier increasingly it's the
damning dossier not one word has been
disproven in fact a lot of it turned out
to be right on the money the dossier
right which looked sort of out there at
first is getting truer and truer and
truer as facts come out but some of the
subs of con content of the dossier we
were able to corroborate in our
intelligence Community assessment it
hasn't been discredited in fact it's
been the opposite corroborated really
yes really oh okay
your
Intel Community has corroborated all of
the details in there the meetings
they were all lying or at best they
didn't care to know the truth the New
York Times Washington Post they got
Pulitzer prizes for their lives but now
will any of these people ever be held
accountable of course not the media mob
is still dishonest the FBI is still
politicized the doj is now weaponized
more than ever and the Democratic party
is pulling all the strings hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else